To continue this problem, we're just going
to apply the distributive property to both
this part of the expression and this part
of the expression. And now we simplify
within each term and combine like terms.
One quick thing to take note of before I
write the final, final answer for this
question, let's look at each of these
terms. First we have x^2.
Now x^2 is just x times x, or x times x. The first
terms, in each of our factors, multiplied
together. Then we have 5 times x, or the
second term of our first factor
multiplied by the first term of our second
factor. Then we have -2x, which is just
-2 times x. The first term from our first factor
times the second term of our second
factor. And lastly, -2 times 5. Or -10, which
is just this factor, 5, times this factor,
-2. So you can see that we've taken every
combination of pairs of terms from these
two factors and multiplied them together
in order to get our final answer, which is
just x^2 + 3x - 10.